maintenant vous êtes riche vous pouvez
pensez pas que les chômeurs ils
pourraient se bouger le cul aller bosser
un peu
soit connaissez Josiane Balasko Emmanuel
Béart Olivier gaspin j'ai vu la télé
vous avez vu la télé c'est bien alors
Mohamed dia en disait souvent dans les
années 60
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors dans les années 70 on disait
souvent que pour s'en sortir il y avait
la boxe et le rock'n roll aujourd'hui
c'est le rappel basket et vous vous avez
utilisé les deux pour vous en sortir
mais voilà pour faire des fringues et
votre histoire est un petit peu une
légende la légende du gosse des cités
qui montent un business mondial
[Musique]
c'est
alors Mohamed vous publiez chez JML
promis à la victoire vous racontez votre
votre destin alors en fait quand le
livre commence vous êtes dans votre
appartement à New York sur la 100e rue
votre rêve américain dites-vous et en
bas il y a un jeune black qui se fait
plaquer contre une bagnole pas par la
police de New York vous dites ça aurait
pu être moi c'est vrai que ça aurait pu
être vous mais aucun moment vous avez
envie de descendre pour aider le mec
c'est des choses que j'ai vu j'ai vu ça
m'arrive souvent de voir des choses
comme ça aux États-Unis et les lois
américaines sont différentes des lois
françaises et vu que je ne connais pas
le droit américain je m'aventure pas
assez de jouer les médiateurs on va dire
les balles sont vite perdu là-bas donc
vous descendez pas dans ces cas-là
j'évite pas dans cette tenue en toute
qu'est-ce qu'il a retrouvé
[Rires]
ok nos parents sont arrivés du Mali donc
à Sarcelles
comme vous dites par Immigration
Airlines vous étiez 7 à l'époque dans 47
mètres carrés alors de vos parents vous
dites avoir hérité la couleur la
religion vous vous êtes musulman
non pratiquant et musulmans donc de
l'Afrique vous dites que vous avez gardé
des origines mais pas de racine
d'ailleurs une fois vous êtes allés au
Mali chez vos parents et vous allez
détester il y avait des moustiques il y
avait c'est pas que j'ai détesté je sais
qu'il y a eu un vrai il y a eu un vrai
décalage j'ai les 13 ans traité de blanc
dès que je me mettais à boire de l'eau
dans le robinet je suis tombé malade
je pense
alors vous dites il paraît que le crime
ne paie pas mais le travail non plus
c'est vrai que vos parents bon vous
dites ils ont galéré pendant 40 ans
8 heures de boulot deux heures de métro
et puis pas tellement de place pour
l'amour ce qui fait qu'ils ont fini par
divorcer au bout d'un moment et votre
mère tient la garde des enfants mais
n'avez pas les moyens d'élever les
enfants et vous vous retrouvez à l'âge
de 3 ans à la DASS alors en sixième vous
retournez à Sarcelles puisque votre mère
a trouvé un boulot comme cuisinière à
Disneyland donc elle peut vous elle peut
vous reprendre vous retourner à
Sarcelles à Sarcelles il y a plusieurs
cité quoi j'habitais en plein milieu et
plusieurs personnes nécessité sont
devenues plus ou moins célèbres
aujourd'hui donc gynéco stony Bugsy
Passy arsenic vous traînez dans les
mêmes cages d'escalier que
j'ai fait même l'école avec eux j'ai
fait des conneries avec eux et puis
voilà quoi à 17 ans petit séjour à
Fleury-Mérogis
petit
pour une bagarre une sorte de scooter
voilà quoi
[Musique]
de faire des conneries et il devient
notre ami Mohamed dia devient livreur
pour une pizzeria casher c'est
extraordinaire quand même
et vous finissez par reprendre la
pizzeria ouais par la suite enfin j'ai
repris la pizzeria parce que tous les on
va dire toutes les semaines se faisait
cambrioler et en fin de compte les gens
qui lui faisaient des misères c'était
des gens qui étaient de ma cité on va
dire donc je devais je devais jouer un
rôle de médiateur mais bon on se fait
pas écouter la clim pardon
donc cette pizzeria dont vous la
reprenez et elle devient le lieu de
rendez-vous de tous les bad boys de la
de la zone si on peut appeler ça des Bad
Boys
non non non non non
pour information je ne fume pas là on
peut dire des choses pizza quand même
non il y avait non c'était c'était moi
qui faisait les pizzas c'était mon pote
qui faisait des livraisons et quand même
beaucoup de contrôle de police qui a
quand même décourager excusez-moi
Mohamed les clients normaux quand même
c'est clair c'est clair ouais on est
d'accord et là alors là vous voulez
quand même non vous avez envie de
réussir c'est vrai vous vous lancez dans
la lecture de mener de pelucilitzer donc
ça c'était un peu votre Bible à cette
époque là c'est quelqu'un que j'admire
beaucoup et qui actuellement est un peu
dans la merde j'étais le voir tout à
l'heure il salue avant et alors bah il
essaie de s'en sortir c'est un battant
et il est
il va s'en sortir mais qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé parce que moi j'ai lu dans
le journal qu'on a retrouvé pauluser
chez lui la gueule défoncé avec du sang
sur les murs non c'était il a eu un
accident je pense qu'il habite dans un
duplex il est tombé de l'escalier bon
bah là il est en train de se dangereux
c'est des couilles qu'on a pas dans les
chambres de bonnes ça je l'ai déjà
donc il a eu un accident et bon là il
est en train de il en rééducation on va
dire ça va c'est très dangereux il est
toujours avec ses charmante polonaise
elle était là d'ailleurs qui est venue
ici qui est magnifique hein je trouve
que l'on parle pas il y a un moment
Paul-Loup passer dans les médias il
était passé dans toutes les émissions
sur les chaînes nationales et depuis cet
accident on en parle pas donc si on en
parle mais comme il est en rééducation
on peut pas l'inviter ouais mais parler
de lui au moins ça serait moi je suis en
train de faire
la semaine prochaine
donc vous vous lancez dans la lecture de
monnaie de pollutions
Athénée voilà ça vous donne des idées
sur votre réussite sociale mon cher
Mohammedia et là vous devenez ça dure
pas très longtemps à vous devenez emploi
jeune vous êtes médiateur vous êtes
grand frère pour moi être médiateur
m'occuper des jeunes qui on va dire
prennent le mauvais exemple donc tu dis
bon ben si à moins de les remettre dans
le droit chemin autant le faire vous
avez remis certains droits je pense pas
non parce que je t'ai pas crédible
quand tu faisais le petit brigand tout
un tout petit et aujourd'hui tu lui dis
arrêter de faire des conneries et laisse
tranquille maintenant tu serais vraiment
crédible c'est un exemple
de quelqu'un qui s'en est sorti c'est
qu'aujourd'hui je leur ai si je me mets
à la à leur faire la morale forcément
ouais moi aujourd'hui dans la vu la
situation que tu as c'est facile de nous
dire ça mais toi tu vis pas ce qu'on vit
ils savent très bien si vous venez du
même coin toi tu viens du un exemple
peut-être même sans en parler ils savent
d'où tu viens moi je veux pas être moi
je veux pas être un exemple hein déjà à
la base un exemple pour moi enfin à part
pour les fringues
tu trouves vachement bien c'est pareil
tout à l'heure ouais ouais bien
justement on en arrive au fringues donc
vous avez 25 ans vos copains passent
Tony Bugsy tout ça il commence à avoir
du succès c'est quand l'époque du
secteur appui du ministère Hammer et
comme vous êtes pas à rappeur et comme
vous n'êtes pas basketteur vous décidez
de vous lancer dans les fringues
justement dans le sportswear trouver une
marque à laquelle les jeunes pourraient
s'identifier et c'est Kenzi le fameux
Kenzi le manager de ministère Hammer qui
vous donne l'idée d'utiliser votre
propre nom on est dans un avion partez à
New York je suis allé voir ma famille et
lui il allait dans un congrès enfin
t'inviter pour un magazine américain et
je lui dis bon voilà je j'ai envie de
créer ma ligne de vêtements j'ai besoin
de d'utiliser les articles du sectorat
mais il y a pas de problème
et puis on était là à se prendre la tête
sur le monde puis après il m'a dit mais
pourquoi tu donnerais pas ton nom et
quand j'ai pensé à mon nom je pensais à
d'autres enseignes qui avaient des qui
étaient en 3 en 3 lettres
un clip de Stomy Bugsy je me suis dit
j'ai vu avec un polo qui était un
partenariat de marque
ça pourrait être pas Marc
tout simplement c'est parti comme ça et
voilà alors là vous rencontrez les
frères caleçons et leur fille Déborah et
puis Joseph Jablonski aussi qui s'occupe
de Lewis et de shot en France shot ses
perfecto donc c'est quand même des gens
importants et là c'est le succès
c'est-à-dire que d'un seul coup vous
passez de 20 à 200 points de vente
ça marche très bien vous êtes dans le
catalogue de La Redoute dans le
catalogue des 3 Suisses enfin tout n'est
pas arrivé d'un coup en général quand tu
arrives tout d'un coup on perd un peu
les plans
on peut dire ça comme ça
[Applaudissements]
mais problème c'est toujours un problème
les Français
du gilet quand même
[Applaudissements]
c'est dans ta loge c'est dans ta loge
malheureusement le 18 avril
le 18 avril 2001 un homme cagoulé c'est
de vous abattre deux tirs à bout portant
assez grave vous avez une opération qui
dure qui dure 8 heures
pourquoi je sais pas je sais pas
peut-être que c'est quand j'ai eu les
moyens de me payer une belle voiture je
me suis payé la belle voiture mais
j'étais toujours j'étais toujours chez
ma mère
ça a pas dû plaire à certaines personnes
et puis voilà quoi et un soir je
descends et puis je rencontre une
personne qui voulait me dire entre
guillemets j'ai pas me régler mon compte
parce que je dirais à l'époque si
vraiment vous voulez me tu m'aurais tué
c'est quelqu'un qui a voulu me faire du
mal parce qu'on m'a tiré c'est quand
même avec la chevrotine c'est pas avec
un 9 mm
vous avez du plomb partout quand même
dans le foie dans le pancréas
et les risques du métier vous savez pas
qui c'est le mec non vous dites c'est un
noir quoi oui parce que j'ai vu que
c'était un ordre
voilà alors à la sortie votre mère
quitte Sarcelles et vous vous décidez de
vous installer aux États-Unis
refuser de ah Laurent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tu as vu l'effet là j'ai envie de dire
[Rires]
et en même temps on en prend pas soin
la peau retourner c'est stressant
j'ai l'impression
c'est pas très tendance à les citer en
ce moment à l'époque c'était tendance à
l'époque aujourd'hui peut-être que là ça
aurait été différent moi j'ai accès
beaucoup ma communication sur le rêve
américain c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
peut-être que j'aurais peut-être pas été
crédible j'ai eu la chance de passer
avant
et là vous rencontrez donc
Jean-Louis
et là vous rencontrez donc Michael
Jordan Tony Parker
avec la NBA alors que vous êtes petit
rappel toujours petit rappelons-le
encore monter un business avec Tariq
abdull wad avec ce que vous portez
d'ailleurs weeklyphe
le producteur de Whitney Houston et
Destiny's Child quand vous faites pour
rencontrer tous ces gens là et devenir
copains avec eux petit à petit on se
fait un nom on se fait des connaissances
et puis après quand on veut contacter
notre personne on passe par une personne
des fois ça marche pas mais le tout
c'est de persévérer et puis voilà quoi
on ne peut pas être riche en France
justement on va voir ça s'appelle
l'interview maintenant que vous êtes
riche
[Musique]
Mohammedia maintenant que vous êtes
riche ça vous fait pas peur tous ces
jeunes de banlieues là
je continue à prendre le métro je prends
le bus donc voilà quoi non maintenant
vous êtes riche vous le trouvez sympa et
on est Antoine Seyer
j'ai jamais fait jamais prêté attention
à ce monsieur maintenant
déjà
je dirais qu'il y a des gens qui sont
riches qui trouvent que le rap c'est
bien donc chacun peut avoir son opinion
maintenant vous êtes riche vous trouvez
que c'est normal de faire fabriquer des
fringues par les enfants exploités en
Asie oui alors pour information mes
vêtements sont pas fait à l'étranger
s'ils ont fait étrangers mais ils ont
fait un Tunisie mais ils sont gérés par
la famille caleçon qui qui gère on va
dire de manière correcte leurs usines et
d'ailleurs je vais tous les six mois
là-bas voir comment ça se passe voilà
quoi maintenant vous êtes riche j'ai des
montres à quoi 10 plaques
[Applaudissements]
son
nom
j'aimerais bien j'aimerais bien
chante-nous ramoneurs
maintenant que vous êtes riche vous
trouvez pas que Chirac il exagère un peu
avec les Américains quand même non
je ne me je ne me mêle pas de politique
c'est pas mon visage
maintenant vous êtes riche vous pensez
pas que les chômeurs ils pourraient se
bouger le cul elle est bosser un peu le
jour où serait riche fait quelque chose
pour les chômeurs
maintenant que vous êtes riche ça vous
fait pas peur tous cette immigration
clandestine
le jour que je ne me sentirai pas
immigré il couleront des dents et pour
être sûr de ne rien rater de Inna
larditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu